the search continues for the identity of
this young boy
found dead near the mountain springs
area on friday
after a misidentification investigators
are back at square one
today they've released this new image
and good evening we do thank you so much
for joining us tonight at five o'clock
i'm sasha loftis
we begin tonight with that developing
story let's head right over to kate
houston
in the studio with the latest kate yes
sasha it's now been over
48 hours since the boy was found by a
group of hikers
now here you can see this original
sketch that was released
this new one now provided by the
national center for missing and
exploited children
and you can really see just how much
more detail this sketch has
investigators hoping this will lead to
some new information
detectives believe the boy is between
the ages of 8 and 12.
he's 411 and weighs 123 pounds due to
where his body was found
near mountain springs and state route
160 police believe he may have lived in
las vegas pahrump
baker or another nearby city according
to police
no local missing children match his
description
project desert angels search and rescue
responded to yesterday's amber alert
which was later called a
misidentification the team says
this new enhanced image is extremely
helpful because the community now needs
as many details as possible
we don't know who this kid is we don't
know where he came from
he could be from anywhere really with
other investigations of this nature it
takes hairline
eyes distinguishing factors
just because not everybody looks the
same there's always
something off police are asking
teachers in particular to pay close
attention to this new
digitally enhanced picture asking anyone
with information
to come forward metro police say that
the boy is the victim of a homicide but
have
not yet released information on the
injuries or how he died
i have reached out to metro for an
update and have not yet heard back
back to you sasha